[Musique]
cette éruption de rayons gamma est la
dernière chose que l'humanité vers avant
d'être annihilé nous sommes assis sur
une poudrière prête à exploser
bruxelles s'intéresse et derrière ou de
l'élu reçues nous avons identifié un
repas avait commencé l'expérience
montrez-moi de quoi vous êtes capables
inutile de résister
à identifier le suspect son nom et
joseph steadman bouclé mois la zone
qu'est ce que vous m'avez fait
commencez à comprendre jo plus vous
laisserez éclater votre colère plus
grand sera votre pouvoir
voyons jusqu'où nous pouvons vous
poussez nous y sommes presque
ce n'est pas suffisant doux
libérez votre puissance
[Musique]
nous n'avons jamais vu une chose
pareille
nous devons fuir la zone
il ne triomphe de la nature qu'en lui
obéissant